alred Senator how's it going tell us
about how your love of biking started I
went to work for a guy named George W
bush and I was doing a little bit of
mountain biking he as you know is a
maniac on a mountain bike yeah and
although he's 10 years older than me uh
the guy can get up and go so he's
punishing he is he loves to punish
people so the one time you and I went M
mountain biking you know that I had an
accident where you don't know I don't
believe is that I fractured five ribs
that day so um today you want to come
through this clean and healthy um you've
had a big accident there right you are
Titanium Man broke the collar bone in
six places I mean if you haven't done
that you really have a mountain bik so I
was doing a little research last night
look at this I did a Google search for
Rob Portman Viking yeah which you find
start to type Rob Portman VI up comes
Rob Portman Viking Rob Portman bikini
what do you what do you think that's
about I don't know I've never biked in a
bikini that I know of so here's what
we're doing scavenger hunt so we're
going to bike around the city as you
solve the clues tell us where we're
going next here's clue one follow the
drive of your home state namesake Ohio
Drive all right right down there you're
solving it as we go here to the memorial
of a man who is a farmer inv ventor and
a thinker whose words are etched in
history Jefferson stopped just short of
this Shrine on the inlet bridge for a
picturesque view of Washington DC so
we're going to ride there
first so how many times a week do you
bike now I used to get out twice a week
yeah if I can and what's like a normal
ride for you how long uh 25 30 mil you
like your chances of getting the
majority I'm certainly not promising it
I think we've over promised and
underperformed tyly as Republicans the
last couple Cycles but I think we've got
better candidates and at the end of the
day I think that's what matters most
more than all the money so yeah I think
I think we'll win what do you think the
move the country so sour now yeah I
think it's you know primarily two things
one is frustration with the economy and
then second I think there's a total
frustration with
Washington we're going to clue two four
be careful if you slice it you may hit
an approaching plane at Ronald Reagan
National Airport continue down the
Buckeye Drive the tip of DC's only
Peninsula you know DC's only Peninsula H
Point hes point we're talking the golf
course at hes Point yeah now was that
too easy
too um I think even the below average
Senator could have got could have gotten
that one yeah we're supposed to be
riding but we can't because our bikes
are locked okay so we got to solve that
right okay the way to unlock the bikes
we go to clue three it's a lot of
pressure I'm going to have you open this
one I think I can get the the lock off
this bike what losing like your Brooklyn
criminal skills really well you know
what if you can't get the clue we'll go
to your David Blaine thing and you'll
get it open 2 three at what political
event did Al Gore utter the word lock
boox seven times this one's a little
harder I see the wheels turning the port
Wheels it's a little ironic that you
don't know the answer to this because to
the extent you have oh it was a debate
there you go it was a debate it was a
debate and I played out exactly in that
debate before I call for the key I want
to see your magic
trick this is like how to boost a bike
Rob Portman style in 60 seconds oh man
done two bikes how many bikes have you
boosted that way GES in Cincinnati do
not take notes do not take take not all
right so we're headed off to haes point
now I'm not asking you to confirm that
vice president Shany sometimes goes
hunting after a couple beers but do you
ever bik drunk on this 100 mile ride I
do every year there's a tradition we
have about 80 m in um at the restop
there's a woman who offers shots of Jack
Daniels and I foolishly partake that
helps in the first uh 5 minutes if you
get in the bike cuz you got that warm
feeling yeah and then you regret it the
rest of the way do you do any bike
stunts you like ride on ride on just the
back wheels or okay here we go you ready
yeah that's like a bike
stunt all right so here we are at our
surprise stop here so we decided to
reward you with your all your glue
solving and biking prowess with a taste
of Ohio now Skyline Chili for those who
don't this is awesome do you know what
the secret ingredient is here a little
bit of chocolate a little bit of
chocolate some say tobacco Juice
masticated by a virgin but that's not
accurate it's a little bit of chocolate
little bit of chocolate how is biking
like Po politics you know some people
even in your own party get competitive
and certainly the other party sometimes
in politics people will throw metal rods
into your wheels yeah politics is a
little more dangerous than biking
despite our respective
injuries